[Music]
i hate having to talk about it but
you have to talk about it yeah talk
about it
you guys know in new york an elderly
asian woman
was randomly beaten yo this was tough
125 times yeah
in a unprovoked attack dude
this was at an atm
um no wasn't she going into her she was
she looking into a building it looks
like an atm vestibule though that's what
it kind of appears to be because it
looked like she was getting into an
elevator or about to and a dude opens up
the door casually and just starts
beating her from the back big ass
[ __ ] too
like socks her in the head on the side
she like falls down and [ __ ] keeps
her he calls her like a racial they're
an asian [ __ ]
um he spat on her too
the woman was 67 years old oh
and the guy um yeah 42 year old dude
with just a shitload of uh priors of
course then you have like 40 something
14 arrests oh 40 okay something like
that
14 arrests
and that's all you have to really say
right yeah 14 previous arrests half of
them felonies
what
i thought they're supposed to well maybe
then he's not in a three strike how the
[ __ ] is this
walking around and [ __ ] you have 14 of
anything dude that's a lot yeah 14
speeding tickets i'm looking at you
weird yeah like kids i'm looking at you
funny yeah anything and you're not asian
yeah yeah 14 kids and
you're not mormon yeah what is that i
mean he was convicted of assault in 2011
released from prison 2013 two and a half
years into his three plus year sentence
i mean they just [ __ ] never keep
these people what kind of crimes were
they
um it doesn't say but right
but that one was assaulted yeah it does
show it's a violent crime so i want to
believe in like rehabilitation and i
want to believe in second chances and i
want to believe that people can grow and
learn depending on their age or whatever
i would love to see and i'm not like all
data science guy but i'd like to see
some data on anyone that has over choose
a number four felonies anyone over four
felonies that has ever
been a positive piece of society what
about 14 chances that's what i'm saying
like no no even less that's what i'm
saying like even two how many people
with two to six felonies come back and
do something awesome for us
i would love to know that because in my
brain like i feel like there's a point
of you're not coming back from this like
like when you hear about the [ __ ]
like the homeless dude that had a bucket
of his own [ __ ] and dumped it on
someone's head yeah when what's after
that yeah what's the upside because i
also feel like you know
when you're conditioned
like you know like an animal that bites
a human right once they taste human
blood they have to put them down right i
also feel like if you've done enough
felonies on society or mankind it's a
condition where like you're you're
reconditioned to go this is okay yeah
for sure yeah right because like even
for me it's like like there's so many
layers where like one i'm not gonna hit
a chick
i'm not definitely not going to hit an
elder so i'm not going to hit an elder
chick
so for someone to just like be at a
point where it's
that's that's that to him is like
hitting another dude or hitting whatever
a [ __ ] well he might even think she's
a gargoyle yeah or like you know like or
that's the michelin man and i gotta
[ __ ] kill him because you know
i'm i'm preventing world war iii yeah so
like we have a lot of mentally disabled
people just out on the streets or
deranged people or people basically who
shouldn't be in our communities right
and so one of the things that i i
realized and i was digging into this
stuff and um it's the reason why it's
happening in certain cities is a lot of
these different prosecutors who believe
in the reform laws
they don't want to file charges or
they're right they're slapping you know
a little thing on the wrist and then
saying that's the statistics that
they're trying to get or they're not
filing a lot of charges on maybe
misdemeanors or small assaults or
whatever right so what ends up happening
is they just get re-released re-released
and then
i get what they're kind of trying to say
here but it sucks because for me the
guys that are behind the reform laws
they didn't do their due diligence they
didn't do their homework a lot of people
want to quote well look at scandinavia
they have a great reform system and i'm
like great stupid reference [ __ ] i'm
like let's
let's mimic something
where
you know they have a good rehabilitation
program they have you know like a
process of after you catch a dude you
throw them through their system we don't
even have that we just say oh you know
what we shouldn't criminalize anymore so
let's just like let them loose right and
then it's like well
i think it's better to catch them keep
them away from society if they have
mental issues and they have violent
tendencies keep them away while we
figure out how to reform and we can run
tests and see what works what doesn't
work we can bring in people from
scandinavia who understand how to
re-educate bring them back into commute
like the community as a safe you know
functioning member of society if we
can't do that then why the [ __ ] should
we leave them out on the streets to
commit more violence that's what i don't
[ __ ] i don't understand either it's
like how is this guy out with violent
felonies if you have two violent
felonies well like where we draw on the
line and then the only thing that i can
think of is it's a political agenda so
for example right you want to get voted
in so you're going to run on reform laws
you're going to run on the the hey we
got to stop criminalizing because all it
does is it locks up the minority
communities which is true
but they don't do their homework they
don't do the actual work to help people
they just
give [ __ ] all this [ __ ] to pander
right so to get the votes they're just
getting the votes right and what they do
is basically
now they don't file charges because if
you don't file charges you can claim
that there's not crime going on there's
no crime yeah so it's like if you don't
file a charge and if you don't file that
there is a crime and people are getting
convicted then your statistics of crime
is low so we feel the crime on the
streets people that walk out there every
day we see
all of this [ __ ] happening but then the
guys on top can say look we had a great
[ __ ] year yeah because look at our
statistics we had no [ __ ] criminals
we always respond with that [ __ ] same
thing right and then what happens it's
like people who don't know maybe they
live in nice little gate gated
communities who don't live in our
neighborhoods go that's awesome we're
doing great let's vote them in again and
i'm like this [ __ ] system sucks dude
yeah yeah
because it seems like all the
asian hate or not whatever like
we we've talked about this a lot
especially on jk all the stories we
cover
where there's an assault a violent crime
happening guess what we find out
priors rap sheet like crazy yeah and it
happens to be in these like more liberal
cities like l.a or yeah so you can and
especially as people that live there
right you can't help but to feel like
what the [ __ ] do we have to do with
citizens
for people for us to be heard just to
get these dangerous people out the
streets like is that so
hard to
ask for but i guess it is a very
difficult
like and also especially with like
uh what seems to be at least through
media it's specifically targeting people
that are like our parents or
grandparents or aunties and uncles you
know that's the part that's like yeah
how do you even stop something that is
like
seems like so specific even though
it might not be because if they could
have mental illness or it might be yeah
have they looked into like is there a
tie of any of this like i know there was
some early stuff with the corona stuff
like just ignorant ass people were tying
that into violence but is the rest of
this just dog [ __ ] also like um
knowing that when you're around like uh
like lunar new year and stuff a lot of
old asian people might be carrying like
money or cash that was that was also
potentially a thing but like when you
see kind of these violent crimes it's
not looking it doesn't look like hey i'm
going to steal your stuff yeah it's like
i'm just going to racially i'm just
going to beat you up like crazy yeah
yeah that's 120 punches i don't get it
it's a little bit confusing because i i
mean i honestly believe for a little bit
that
most of the attackers
were mentally unstable homeless people
because it was a lot of that [ __ ] just
like people that would just do random
ass [ __ ] have nothing to do all day
nowhere to go and they just do some
crazy [ __ ] yeah because you see that
everywhere but this [ __ ] guy
specifically has a normalized instagram
account
not private yeah you could just look
he's just a reg he just looks like a
regular [ __ ] dude yeah and and they
just like crossed each other by the door
yeah and he didn't even leave afterwards
he just like hung around and they
arrested him in front of the building
i don't understand but they said oh he's
got a history of mental like
disabilities or or a history of
something but i'm like that's a weird
court thing too right like sometimes you
get let off easier that way and stuff
yeah i don't understand that either like
i have empathy for mental illness don't
get me wrong but like if you're out
punching [ __ ] yeah but you know
like what a guy i know bro there's a guy
that we go we went to high school with
this dude is going he's like he was a
normal guy he's army and cat his name is
jeff gebb or something now he's all over
these instagram accounts called who's
gone wild you ever seen those guys who's
gone he's like in his car and he's like
let me like let me talk to you my girl
baby girl he's trying to holler at girls
on instagram and like he's for content
but he's not the same like he's
different like i see him around like i
know this dude like we knew this guy
he's a different guy now however he was
in high school he's a different guy but
this dude is on instagram blowing up
everyone loves this [ __ ] dude but
he's just filming himself in his in his
car talking about how he wants to holler
at girls he's like don't hate me because
i'm bald and i'm horny baby like he says
crazy [ __ ] but he's like a [ __ ] star
like on instagram yeah but if you watch
his videos you're like
something's different i don't know what
it is he knew him from before yeah like
something he's
you know i mean he's about to snap or
some [ __ ] not that he's about to snap
but it's like
talking about the mental illness [ __ ]
like like it's such a special he can
seem kind of coherent yeah but you don't
know what's really ticking really don't
you really don't know right like and he
has a normal instagram account kind of
you know and all that [ __ ] but like he's
not violent necessarily sure sure is
there a video of him getting in a fight
with a guy at the grove and he pulls a
knife on him yeah there is but that was
in like self-defense but it but it's so
[ __ ] weird though like as far as the
mental health thing so what bart was
saying too though i think this is where
you're going with it it's like we call
it mental illness or you know what i
mean but why why such a consistent
string of like the same type of victim
yeah yeah like every week this is how no
for sure you're not really seeing it on
the news unless you're kind of looking
for it or unless [ __ ] instagram's
algorithm is pushing it to you because
you've already seen a lot of this stuff
and you're that's part of your community
but like it's happening every weekend
like another i literally was just
scrolling through i just story during
the break and it's like a another dude
31 year old dude like
just wailed on a kid like an asian lady
and then the [ __ ] kid you see that
one a kid in a baby carriage three years
old and just like beat the crap out of a
kid a baby for sure
and it's like and yeah also of asian
descent so you're kind of like
is it was it a homeless man was it like
because most of the videos i saw was
like um
basically dudes that are probably
drugged up and homeless but why why are
the victims similar why why is it always
like also but they could both be all
true and also yeah and also if it's like
let's say uh
when are we gonna get to a point where
we feel like there might be an asian
hate crime pandemic so like let's say
uh it's
maybe it's nine out of ten
of the people getting well done is
asians right maybe that's not enough
then is it 99 out of 100 or is it 9 000
out of
9
nine
10
thousand out of a million like what's
the number that we're like okay this is
uh too big of a venn diagram to just go
lots of mental illness lots of asians
you know well um
one thing for sure is during the
pandemic and on
senseless violence just like random acts
of murder up everywhere that is murders
just straight up beating the [ __ ] out of
people without any like maybe like
without any any monetary gain like
before it's like yeah grab their wallet
[ __ ] them up
it's just senseless violence has been
dramatically up
in many major cities
and so that's one and i think to
compound on top of that are the reform
laws because
another thing that i studied is um in
honolulu like i have friends in the
police department there it's the same
thing same exact thing the prosecutor
does not want to prosecute they want to
do all this stuff they have um you know
molesters touchers gropers
their crime isn't that hardcore maybe
they'll grope tourists or women walking
around right so it's not hardcore enough
for them to go to jail but what they'll
do is they'll catch and release catch
and release the cops feel helpless
because they catch the guy but they
can't file a charge or they they do a
little thing and hold them and then they
gotta let them go so what ends up
happening i think psychologically to
people that are like this right is they
feel bolder with their crimes so
at what point does it have to be after
the fact this guy raped someone that
finally we could put him away right or
like i think that's the kind of [ __ ]
that's happening right it's like
at what point do we prevent this crime
like oh he's only pawn someone it's cool
let's let him go it's not a big deal and
then oh he's only stabbed someone and
then what's what's the next one right oh
he's only killed three people you know
and i think that's the
natural progression of allowing people
to
do something
and then they they don't have any
consequences
and there's no fear of getting caught
now they can continue to do whatever
they want to because they know that
nothing's going to happen i think that's
the main when you look at everything and
you just plot it all out in a big graph
you could have some people go oh it's
because they're all black oh it's
because they're all homeless oh it's
because we're all this those are all
like incorrect the one main common
denominator is none of those people were
afraid of what would happen to them
that's the number one uh
i feel like
common denominator with all of it and
that stems from laws and consequences
that don't exist that they're not afraid
of and that's all it is whatever the
[ __ ] thing we [ __ ] up and voted for
to make that the case we need to reverse
that [ __ ] yeah yeah and my thing is i
really think it's because of the
prosecutor that we have in there because
we do have people in law enforcement
they're like dude we're catching they're
trying yeah they're really watching
but we we feel helpless because they get
released back onto the streets well yeah
even in the areas like where barbell is
and the brewery and then we asked the
police like what can we do about this
these chop shops and these meth labs
that are just here on the street and
they were like we can't do anything
until a certain number of people will
complain and then even at that point if
we get them to move not we're not there
to keep them from coming back
so there's absolutely they're just
powerless like these cops are like it's
not our law like we didn't vote for this
to happen like that's you guys voted for
them to be treated that way and we just
comply
you can't ask the cops to do anything
yeah i mean and even if they do grab
them
they can't keep them in jail no they
can't do anything there was another one
where um it started before the pandemic
and
i used to be super for uh
decriminalizing drugs right because you
know i was you know you know into drugs
and all that and i was like dude it
sucks like if i get caught with drugs
like i shouldn't do 10 years it's weird
as a drug user but then
what ended up happening as a partaker
right
i was like well this is what i started
considering and i talked to my buddy
who's a cop too he was like well look it
like if drug is criminalized right what
we can do is if this guy's high off his
balls or if he's jonesing for more right
what happens when someone wants crack
and i'm like
if they don't have money they'll break
into homes because that's what me and my
buddies did or whoever right and then
he's like exactly so this is crime
prevention so um if it's criminalized we
don't have to slap on a crazy you know
10-year final or or or sentence on them
we could hold them in the cell let them
sober up and then at least he's not a
threat to society for those days he goes
if i can't criminalize this [ __ ] they're
out onto the streets and they're and
then it increases the crime and i'm like
oh [ __ ] i didn't even see it that way
but it is first-hand account troop my
friends when they did when they ran out
of money for drugs to start breaking
into homes they start purse snatching
they start doing all those things right
so then
we do have a huge drug problem and so i
i think it's the same thing with the
reform laws it comes from a good place
where it's like yeah you shouldn't
criminalize laws because you know you
don't want to make somebody a criminal
for smoking a joint but at the same time
how are you going to create a system to
support these guys to get off
and then maybe the government can find a
method where these guys don't go out and
break into homes because they need more
drugs or whatever we just need a system
of better uh rehabilitation and unless
that's in
right now the best system we do have is
maybe keeping them away safe from you
know threatening people on the streets
that's what scares me is that people on
the extreme left they're saying like oh
don't put them in jail don't criminalize
them don't don't do any of that
use this other unknown magic of
rehabilitation that does not yet exist
yeah we don't have that yet so why are
you stopping doing this when we don't
have that imaginary solution i just want
to know if the people that are voting
for this stuff actually live among
amongst the poor i don't think they do
no because i highly believe like all
these people that are like voting for it
they're like maybe rich white guilt
people that live in gated communities
and
they don't live amongst the people that
like
that are dealing with yeah they for sure
probably don't see it well now they're
actually getting victimized too with all
these robberies in beverly hills and bel
air and all that [ __ ] so i don't know
what seth rogen [ __ ] about oh my god
[ __ ] seth rogan the [ __ ] out of here
i never had my car broken
he said that's that's what it's like
living in the city yeah it's like it's a
part of living in a city we should just
be okay with it i got it i mean i'm
telling you in tokyo is way more
populated but [ __ ] you don't have cars
broken into left and right
oh